[Music]
bullseye everybody it seems like we're
genuinely gonna get the character on the
TV show finally we've been asking for
him for three seasons I think that we're
just working up to it it sounds like
he's gonna have a pretty interesting art
to like they're kind of combining a
couple different versions of the
character so we'll try to explain what's
going on if you guys don't know who
bullseye is or why everybody's freaking
out about him or you're not a big comic
book person but be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos daredevil
season 3 will be dropping later this
year but they probably won't confirm the
actual premiere date till Comic Con this
summer
just a reminder to that we're also
getting Luke Cage season 2 at the end of
June so that will drop before Comic Con
so we might also get a little bit of a
teaser at the end of that for daredevil
season 3 I think most people understood
the teaser at the end of defenders that
we're gonna be doing born again because
they gave a shout out to Matt Murdock's
mom in real life gets sister Maggie
sister Maggie is his mother in the
comics they cast Joanne Whalley to play
the character she's a pretty notable
actress so that's sort of the bones of
the overstory but bullseye was not a
part of the born-again story it was
mostly just kingpin versus daredevil but
what the TV show seems like it's doing
is the FBI is gonna be a big
organization during the season like
homeland security was a big deal during
Punisher season 1 but there are a couple
big things that are happening during
daredevil season 3 namely the trial of
the kingpin but as part of that kingpin
also said that he was coming for Matt
Murdock during daredevil season 2 not
the daredevil kingpin also wants to take
down the daredevil but he doesn't know
that Matt Murdock is daredevil yet so
you have kingpin coming for daredevil on
all fronts in during the born-again
storyline he finds out Matt Murdock
secret identity it just systematically
starts to destroy his life he tears him
down
so the daredevil can be born again
quote-unquote you get the idea so that's
kind of what Matt's arc is going to be
during daredevil season 3
he's been torn down he almost died now
it's his chance to be born again but the
whole thing with bullseye during
daredevil season 3 is that we thought
that they were going to cast him there
was a casting notice for a character
that
sounded like a version of bullseye from
the comics that was a little bit
different from what most people know but
then it seems like we got what seems
like pretty solid confirmation because
somebody on the crew posted this picture
of the official logo for season three
and it has bull's eyes signature
comic-book symbol right above the D as
if he's going to be targeting daredevil
during season three but you know how
does that tied together what's going on
with the born again storyline the
kingpin Matt Murdock in the daredevil
character himself so the casting notice
for the character that it seems like is
going to be TV show bull's eye is
actually listed with a code name of
Steve he's supposed to be an FBI agent
described as being kind of awkward and
needing the structure of the bureau to
keep the darkness inside him subdued so
if you're not a big comic book reader
you kind of need to know the history of
daredevil versus bullseye to know how he
sort of pushed bullseye over the edge by
kicking his ass one too many times
so the bullseye character debuted during
daredevil 131 just as this simple
extortionist that was trying to pump up
his reputation so he wanted to take on
the daredevil to prove to the underworld
of the city that he was a total badass
please hire me so I make lots of money
so daredevil kind of gets beaten he
becomes a relatively big mercenary in
the city working for the mob the first
time that anybody ever actually hires
bullseye to go after daredevil is
actually a mob boss in daredevil 141
that hires him not to go after daredevil
but to go after Matt Murdock because
remember nobody knows his secret
identity yet so bullseye goes after Matt
Murdock gets his ass handed to him by
daredevil couple issues later challenges
daredevil to a rematch on live
television to regain his reputation
because all the mob bosses think he's
trash now of course daredevil beats his
ass again and he slowly starts to go
insane so like you remember the Colin
Farrell version of bullseye from the
daredevil movie he had this like insane
quality to him
[Music]
so what might be going on with the TV
show is that you have TV bullseye
working as an FBI agent trying to
investigate the history of the kingpin
what happened during defenders like this
big shadow organization it's slowly
uncovering details about how daredevil
was involved with that so he's going
after daredevil vigilante vigilantes
exist in this gray area they're kind of
against the law they do illegal things
even though it's for good reasons trying
to take down criminals but you can kind
of see how Matt Murdock gets caught in
the crossfire as the FBI is
investigating office so he probably gets
his ass handed to him by daredevil while
he's trying to take him in slowly gets
pushed over the edge over the course of
the season until he eventually turns
into bullseye till he gets co-opted by
the kingpin who then hires him to
directly go after Matt Murdock in a
future season so I don't think that
they're gonna kill off bullseye
during daredevil season 3 I think we're
actually gonna see him get a version of
the kingpin origin story
we're like he starts out of this normal
FBI agent that just slowly goes insane
and succumbs to the darkness within him
because daredevil kicks his ass so many
times at every corner but I think the
real question is is is how many people
besides the kingpin will learn Matt
Murdock secret identity because that's
the whole idea is like once he finds out
that Matt Murdock is the daredevil
that's really when he gets the upper
hand so obviously there's probably a lot
from that born-again storyline that
they're not going to do like Karen Paige
is gonna be this drug-addicted person
that sells out Matt Murdock's secret
identity that's actually what happened
in the comics so kingpin obviously has
his hands in a lot of pies a lot of drug
dealers are on his food chain so Karen
page is eventually compelled to give
over daredevil secret identity to this
drug dealer to get more drugs the drug
dealer passes the information up the
food chain to kingpin
and that's how he learns Matt Murdock
secret identity so obviously they're
probably not going to be doing that
version of events on the TV show it'll
probably be people investigating the
history of kingpin in the city in all
these weird goings-on
the devil of Hell's Kitchen in what
happened during defenders sort of
connecting the Matt Murdock dots to
we're daredevil has been popping up like
how come Matt Murdock is associated with
all these things that Daredevils
associated with and they're just putting
two and two together oh my god Matt
Murdock is the devil of Hell's Kitchen a
lot of people are thinking that this FBI
agent will become TV bullseye is it
because so many versions of the bullseye
character have worked for governmental
organizations before they succumb to the
quote-unquote darkness within them it
just go full-blown mercenary so let me
know in the comments what do you think
about them giving bullseye sort of a
season-long Ark the way they gave
kingpin a development arc like he starts
out as Wilson Fisk becomes the kingpin
by the end of the season so it sounds
like the same thing is gonna be
happening with bull's eye but also
really funny news too because Charlie
Cox the actor has been filming daredevil
season 3 for a while now he hasn't seen
infinity war so he was actually at a
Comic Con recently where people were
asking him questions about that like
what do you think about the snap sure
what's going on with that where did the
show fall in the timeline he says that
he has no idea what the ending of
infinity war was so he didn't know about
everybody getting erased so I think
that's confirmation that daredevil
season 3 and also Luke Cage season 2
pretty much every new season of the
Netflix series are happening right
before the snap right before the black
order comes to the sanctum to get the
time stone what'll probably happen is is
they'll wait till after Avengers for
whichever seasons fall after that to
reference the events of infinity war
depending on how they resolve things
like if they wipe everyone's minds so
that nobody remembers that half of the
universe got erased that seems like it's
going to be a bit of a plot point so
there are a number of ways to explain
how they reference or don't reference
things on the Netflix series in the next
couple of years but there is a whole
video that I'm working on I'll try to
post as quick as possible leave all your
requests in the comments below
but click here for all my other
daredevil season 3 videos and click here
for that brand new ant-man and the wasp
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight